bonjour à tous on va parler aujourd'hui
du huawei p20 light le pays bas étaient
attendus avec le p 20 il fait 20 pro le
27 mars prochain
sauf qu'en réalité le calendrier a été
bousculé le pays 20 light est déjà
commercialisé dans certains pays pas
partout du coup on a la fiche technique
on a les annonces officielles
on a tous et justement on va en parler
maintenant
le bénin light je l'attendais pour le 27
mars je suis très surpris qu'il soit
arrivé plus tôt on comprenait vraiment
l'intérêt stratégique de huawei 60 et 3
nouveaux produits l'enor qui note du 27
mars
p20 p20 pro et produits d'entrée de
gamme le pépin light sauf que le p 20
était déjà sortie est c'est fait exprès
de faire sortir plutôt est ce par le
biais de fuite je sais pas toujours est
il que ce pépin light est là bien
présent et on va regarder tout de suite
sa fiche technique voir s'il intéressant
oui non à qui s'adresse et puis d'ici
quelques jours et c'est collector
abonnez-vous parce qu'on va parler du p
20 p 20 pro et qui est à mon avis on
mettre une grande claque à son reste ça
va super intéressant parce qu'on voit
que samsung avec sa galaxy s 9 et s9
plus a voulu un appareil photo
réinventer la huawei avec le pays 20 et
surtout le p r impro veulent vraiment
continuer à mettre l'appareil photo au
centre avec de l'intelligence
artificielle
alors je tisse très rapidement on aura
du super slow motion on aura un appareil
photo 3 capteurs qui permettra de capter
toujours mieux la luminosité est d'aller
toujours plus loin avec les jeux de
lumière les jeux d'ombrés enfin quelque
chose qui va être super intéressant que
soit sur la photo la vidéo
d'ailleurs on se posera la question là
dessus quel smartphone acheter si vous
voulez un super photophone entre le
galaxy s 9 aces n'a plus l'épée 20 ep20
trop mais ça on en reparle d'ici
quelques jours donc abonnez vous et
restez connectés pour l'heure on va
parler du p 20 light le pétain light
c'est tout autre chose on parle pas
effectivement de grandes innovations au
niveau de l'appareil photo tout ça bien
sûr on n'a toujours pas parler
d'intelligence artificielle sur ce
produit mais néanmoins un produit tout
nouveau qui arrive dans cette gamme un p
20 light qui est déjà présenté dès
aujourd'hui et donc c'est super cool
comme beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
modèles en 2018 le pays 20 light a lui
aussi sa petite encoche sa petite
encoche n'aura pas effectivement
l'iphone dit samba que tous les
constructeurs a quasiment tous en tout
cas énormément constructeurs se
positionne par rapport à apple et à
l'encoche de l'iphone 10 est-ce que ça
va devenir un nouveau standard je suis
pas sûr
samsung fait de la résistance ils ont
bien raison parce qu'il faut propose
effectivement une alternative et une
gamme très variée
toujours est il que ce nouveau produit à
sa petite en cochant haut pour pouvoir
positionner sans haut parleur sa caméra
en bas de l'écran on retrouve le lot
huawei à l'appareil vous retrouvez votre
capture des empreintes digitales votre
appareil photo un produit je trouve en
tout cas qui est plutôt bien réussi très
sympa qui surtout va avoir un design qui
va se rapprocher vraiment des standards
de huawei 2018 duper vin et du fait d'un
pro à l'avant vont trouver un écran 5,84
pouces eee psc du lcd avec une
résolution de 2280 par 1080 pixels au
format 19/9 et qui occupe 95 5%
dia face avant donc un grand écran
plutôt bien immersif correspond au
format actuel au format de 2018 là où
envoyer qu'en 2017 on avait beaucoup de
formats 18/9 là on arrive dans le 19 9e
est ce qu'il ya un intérêt
je suis pas convaincu mais en tout cas
c'est vraiment un format qui tend à
s'imposer cette année
côté puissance on a un processeur kirin
659 octas core cadencé à 2,36 giguère 4
gigas de ram 64 giga de stockage que
vous pouvez monter jusqu'à 250 gigas
grâce à une carte microsd
il tombe dans l'android 8.0 avec une
surcouche maison le mei 8.0 à l'arrière
vous avez un double appareil photo 13
mégapixels 2 mégapixels le 13 et gap xl
il ya une ouverture de f 2.0
alors ne cherchez pas des choses
extrêmement lumineuse il devrait faire
de bonnes photos lorsque vous avez une
bonne lumière ambiante le 2 méga pixels
vous n'allez pas l'utiliser pour faire
des photos particulier mais juste pour
travailler sur le mode portrait pour
ajouter légère profondeur de champ et
vous permettra également de prendre en
charge le hdr vous avez une double carte
sim alors effectivement les double carte
sim arrive en force en 2018 c'est
intéressant pour les frontaliers pour
les usages professionnels ou pour les
gens qui vont partir à l'étranger
pendant quelques temps pour le commun
des mortels je ne suis pas sûr qu'ils
aient un réel intérêt côté bluetooth
vous avez dû 4.2 il a une batterie de
3000 milliampères heures écoutez
dimension il fait 71 2 par 148,6 par 7 4
mm d'épaisseur et tout ça pour un poids
de 145 g il est proposé en trois coloris
noir bleu rose et tous à un tarif de 369
euros
bien évidemment ce huawei p20 light je
ne manquerai pas de le tester pour vous
dire ce que j'en pense
est ce qu'il est intéressant par rapport
à la concurrence dans cette gamme de
prix
oui ou non est ce qu'il apporte vraiment
quelque chose en attendant il devrait
vraiment profiter du p 20 et du pev un
pro pour coller à l'image
même si c'est un pépin light même si on
est sur un produit d'entrée de gamme
entre et milieu de gamme plutôt d'entrée
de gamme à mon avis il devrait vraiment
profiter cette appellation et ça devrait
permettre effectivement away de booster
les ventes
voilà un peu ce qu'on peut dire dès
aujourd'hui j'attends effectivement des
rôles produits pour vous en parler
d'avantagé pour vous réaliser un test
complet je vous invite à vous abonner
parce qu'on va parler très rapidement du
web et 20 p 20 prot lors de la keynote
qui aura lieu le 27 mars
restez connectés abonnez vous et vous
allez voir regard plein de choses super
cool qui vont arriver
je vous invite comme d'habitude abc des
jolis pouces a marqué tous vos
commentaires vos questions aux
suggestions tout ce que vous voulez bien
évidemment je vous fais des gros bisous
je vous dis à très bientôt
prenez soin de vous n'oubliez pas vous
êtes les meilleurs et puis surtout le
bisou ciao
[Musique]